de quoi parle-t-on est ce voulu raconter
tout va bien un championnat olivier
afonso tête de liste unie pour voisins
souhaitent une proximité avec les
habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux le
candidat s'est allié avec thierry
gastaud les deux conseillers municipaux
de l'opposition de la commune souhaite
faire face à alexandra rosetti maire
sortante avec thierry nous avons partagé
plusieurs moments lors de ce mandat et
l'union s'est fait naturellement les
jambes connais j'ai passé 10 ans à
présider la nasl qui est là
l'association syndicale libre qui est la
plus importante à voisins donc je suis
un élu de terrain et sur le terrain
justement ça coince côté circulation dus
aux nombreuses constructions des
problématiques abordées lors de la
réunion publique mais aussi le manque de
médecins
il faut soit prêt soit adapter les
infrastructures qui vont avec on le fait
marrer je crois qu'il faut un pôle
médical aussi au centre minaj les
seniors ont beaucoup de mal à se
déplacer
parmi les propositions le candidat
souhaite mettre en place un service de
transport propres pour assurer les
déplacements des aînés à l'intérieur
deux voisins mais aussi s'occuper des
jeunes olivier affronte sceaux souhaite
la création d'une halle des sports sur
les terrains de tennis du grand pré
actuellement à l'abandon le candidat
souhaite redynamiser la ville et créer
plus de liens qu'il a énormément de
projets surtout pour les jeunes comme
faire des événements à la fin du mois
cette liste est très représentatif de la
population de voisins qui cherchent à
obtenir plus de convivialité
olivier afonso va à la rencontre des
habitants tous les mercredis de 18h à
20h au bar de la providence à voisins le
bretonneux